six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try again with the 404
caller because we tried with them before
and couldn't hear them 404 are you hey
can you hear me we can't who's this hey
this is Jeff from Atlanta how you doing
go ahead Jeff good good I saw your video
on camera shadow analytics it was really
good and I'm really appreciated but you
asserted that Russian attack the DNC
correct well what I asserted is that
we've now learned that gusoff er was a
particular geography still and that's
not it's not my assertion in other words
I'm transparent in the source so that
you're agreeing with that particular
narrative that the Russia that it was a
hack from either Lucifer or some
Russians correct it's not that I'm
agreeing or disagreeing with a narrative
I've reported on where that information
came from and that's that's the
assertion that's been made okay well
anyway let me get to my my main point I
found an article are you familiar with
the nation yes I am okay I found an
article published on the nation and its
title is a new report raises big
questions about last year's DNC hack now
this is an article sources veteran
intelligence professionals for insanity
and their report in which argued based
on their investigation that the theft of
the DNC emails was not a hack but some
sort of leak like and they provide some
compelling evidence to back up this case
one piece of evidence was data transfer
rate and so the data transfer rate was
something like twenty two point seven
megabytes per second but unfortunately
you cannot get those kinds of speeds
over the Internet and apparently goose
affair was being was hacking from
Romania this faster speeds they could
come up with was eleven point eight okay
well done a second Jeff hold on a second
Jeff gusoff er 2.0 claimed to be
Romanian that was immediately in doubt
because the Romanian that goose
was communicating in was terrible
Romanian so it didn't make any sense
yeah yeah but hold on a second hold on a
second hold on a second
it's the issue if you're citing the
impossibility of a Romanian in your
internet connection being that fast it
is an issue if we've learned that the
person in question isn't Romanian right
that that would be a well no it's more
about the fact that it couldn't have
been a hack because speed was too fast
well then why did I bring up Romania as
a place where they wouldn't have well I
was just I was just I was just sort of
carrying on the conversation that that
establishes that it was an outside of
the country hack and that's not possible
at the transfer rate the transfer rate
is is too high that it would it would
literally have you be someone literally
had to stick a thumb drive into a USB
port and download the information Oh
I've not seen this Oracle but I have
seen that particular option weeded out
tweet it to you I'll tweet it to you
because it's it's it's pretty
interesting in this this is VIP s tips
veterans for veteran intelligent
professionals for insanity this was for
me this seems to be a pretty reliable
source I couldn't really have heard out
well if they were formed in 2003 to
counteract the Bush and his alleged
weapons of mass destruction they were
saying wait we have no evidence for this
so I tend to believe that this could be
a credible source okay what would change
your mind
what would tell you that that report is
wrong and that gusoff er was a GRU
intelligence officer well I say let's
say they retracted this if the nation
came out and retracted this article and
and then someone else provided
compelling evidence and in every in a
study has done by a dips that says oh
you were inaccurate that that's the
scientific method is the way you go so
let me ask my if I'm curious I'm curious
Jeff and the reporting that mr. Furr was
a specific Russian GRU operative the
scientific method as you like to call it
has revealed that the reason they know
that is because of an unmasked IP
address connected specifically to a
particular Russian intelligence facility
in MA
scowl do you you just not believe that
cuz that's really specific evidence
isn't it well I mean that is specifics
but that doesn't contradict the fact
that it couldn't it did that the actual
leak was someone sticking the thumb
drive into a computer not someone on a
mat some foreigner town guy on the
Internet uh not a 400-pound guy okay
alright Jeff you know listen why best of
luck with that best of luck with that I
appreciate the call I mean Jeff always
calls with something like this and he's
just yeah I senses Jeff is a lost cause
you know okay let's take a quick break
please don't hang up if you're on hold
we will take more calls in a moment